No this isn’t some alien plant species,
though it may look pretty strange.
This is actually a team of robots working
together to build a structure by winding fibers
into tubes.
Step 1: the winding arm pulls fiber and resin
from a tank on the ground, mixes the materials
in the nozzle and winds the wetted fiber around.
Step 2: the robot turns on an ultraviolet
light to cook and harden the fiber.
Step 3: using a tiny motor and wheels, the
robot inches itself up on top of the hardened
fiber.
Then, the process begins again.
The robot can change directions by angling itself
at the top of the recently printed section.
And it can use different winding patterns
to change the strength of the build.
The swarming bots are also able to communicate with
each other through a computer network.
This allows them to avoid running into each
other or other obstacles that might be in
their path.
Together, the team of robots can find the
most efficient way to build a structure.
Researchers think this technology could be
used to build structures in remote or dangerous
environments.
Like after an extreme weather event.
They might look a little strange, but these
“Fiberbots” are a well-choreographed construction crew.